okay let's go let's talk to let's talk
to our caller from the five one three
area code who's calling today from five
one three
hey David R this is okhla for from
Cincinnati Ohio hey-oh what's going on
um yeah so I just have two quick
questions so the first question is in
regards to what Ronald Reagan said to
Richard Nixon I don't know if you've
seen this article but it's a bomb of
Ronald Reagan talking the next said
about his complaints about NASA
delegation in the UN he called them
monkeys yeah and he said that they
looked uncomfortable and shoes and I
mean honestly like looking at it I'm not
really surprised that he set that up but
a lot of people including my
conservative friends are so I just
wanted to get your thoughts on that
I'm not hugely surprised you know Nixon
has his whole host of extremely
anti-semitic comments that he would make
even to Henry Kissinger who is himself
Jewish I mean it's great it's crazy I
don't find it hugely surprising it
doesn't mean that I necessarily assumed
there was tape of Reagan calling black
people monkeys and now it's just like
obviously we've uncovered it it's just
not hugely surprising and you know
Reagan's entire in a less cartoonish way
Reagan's entire story an imagery around
like the welfare queen with the Cadillac
or whatever the details kind of escaped
me now it's extremely racially tinged
and and sort of contains dog whistles so
no none of its really surprising to me
yeah I just find it interesting because
the Republicans themselves on being the
party of Reagan and yeah party of Trump
in it turns out that you know both of
those people are pretty racist but I'm
just going on to my second question I
was watching you around so yesterday
about how to lose against Trump in the
first one was really interesting to me
on you know how you know letting Trump
set the narrative there's a way to help
them win so I guess my question is what
can we do to like not allow Donald Trump
to set the narrative
I know that every time he says something
blamele racist
you know we and like the news media you
know cover up certain days upon days
upon days and it just seems like a big
distraction for me it's just it's not
that we ignore so like an example would
be with the Baltimore racist stuff the
debate shouldn't be for five days about
is it or isn't it racist and is he
definitely referring to black people
when he uses infestation type language
or only maybe like that allows him to
set the narrative we can talk about this
is a president who uses Twitter as a
propaganda tool here are all the things
that he is doing while this debate rages
and these are the things that are
extraordinarily damaging to Americans
Trump's personal view about whether
Baltimore is or isn't infested is much
less relevant than what he's actually
doing at the border than what he's doing
on trade etc so we don't pretend like
Twitter doesn't exist but we should
cover it in a way where we critique it
as a propaganda tool that Donald Trump
is using rather than just have debates
about how racist were the comments if
that makes sense yeah yeah thank you for
taking my call man all right oh great to
hear from you great to hear from people
all over the country okay great we will
talk to you again very soon